the following contains spoilers for the
upcoming season of Game of Thrones hey
guys
then I'm going to talk about fatal skill
manipulator and the most cunning man in
Seven Kingdoms today I'm going to talk
about a fate of Lord Petyr Baelish known
as Littlefinger this video is supported
by leaked plot and few tears of mine
Littlefinger's faith is more than
interesting so let's just jump into it
Littlefinger has been one of the biggest
villains since the first season Petyr
Baelish orchestrated the assassination
of John Aron which led that start to
become the new hand of the king he had
been part of Peters plan in the first
season the most prominent action of
Littlefinger is his betrayal on his
stark and the same betrayal is
responsible for almost every event in
Westeros during the war of the five
kings
Littlefinger's we can call a genius plan
back in season one was to kill Jon Arryn
which he did and then to make Ned Stark
is the new hand of the king whereupon he
helped nan to figure out who Joffrey's
real father is since he knew that it
would glad Honorable Ned to reveal the
truth to everyone else which led to Ned
Stark's beheading all of this was
Littlefinger's game he threw the Seven
Kingdoms into a state of chaos from
which he personally benefited not that
we know Peters ultimate plan which he
revealed to Sansa in the gods with a
winner file which is to sit on the Iron
Throne which sends a star by his side
and to rule the Westeros as we could see
by his face expression Jon Snow being
proclaimed as the king in the north
is his impediment to accomplish his plan
Douglas Lee Petyr Baelish will try as
best as he can to make a conflict
between Jon Snow and the North
Littlefinger set himself his plan which
will allowed him to conquer the Iron
Throne contain Sansa Stark is his wife
and as a queen in North which would
provide him the support of the north the
necessary amount of army to have a
chance of conquering the Iron Throne
which Littlefinger almost accomplished
by helping Sansa to retake Winterfell
from Bolton's but lady Moorman disrupted
Baelish his plan to set sense as the
Queen in the north with her magnificent
speech which led other Lords to proclaim
Jon as the king in the north
Petyr Baelish demanded betray Ned Stark
in favor to set up a fight between
wolves and lions demanded poison Joffrey
Lance turned Jo
zone wedding with help of Elena Terrell
- let's call it save Sansa Stark and
then that same save girl already
tortured by Lannister's handing over to
even more sick oppressor Ramsay Bolton
all in favour to turn the north against
the Bolton's and to give him an
opportunity to send sense as the queen
in north the man that first married and
then killed Liza arraign and now his
manipulated her son Robbie rain only
favored to have his own army not
particular his because the Knights of
the Vale are under command of Robin
Arryn my Robin Arryn is as I've already
said manipulated and is now we could say
under the command of Littlefinger here's
the one fact that confirms my statements
Petyr Baelish commits robbing a train to
you the Knights of the Vale to help his
cousin Sansa Stark after she escaped the
clutches of Ramsay Bolton which Robin at
first didn't want to but eventually
Littlefinger kumis Robin - let's call it
obey his orders as I've already said in
one of previous videos Littlefinger
played a big role in John's victory
actually if Petyr Baelish didn't decide
to help John Ramsay Bolton would have
been still alive and would have been in
charge of Winterfell while John would
have been dead but don't think that
Petyr Baelish came to say John don't
think that he would even come to save
Sansa it wasn't for his own good
all of this Littlefinger played in favor
to bring back when I felt a sense a
stark which he managed to accomplish but
his main plan to send sense as a rule
Winterfell and as a queen ignored did
not accomplish the men that made all
these actions regardless on pain that he
brought many people and regardless on
the fact that with his own mekka nations
he destroyed my house and almost
destroyed few others this man Petyr
Baelish will doubtlessly give his best
to make his plans come true which would
bring more in some people in danger of
his increase from leaked photos we got
absolutely nothing the only few if he
can even call it League photos were
taken while Aiden Gillen aka
Littlefinger was preparing for a
shooting set while leaked photos gave us
nothing Lichtblau gave us something not
much but better than nothing
let me worry about this leak blood
the sentences or should I call it events
in it may or may not be true so don't
take it 100% true well I have to admit
that a lot of other events from leaf
plot are strongly connected with leaked
photos but however let's get back on the
topic according to leaked plot little
thing little time to turn aria and sense
against each other by using an old
letter that sends a roadtrip stark under
sources commands also by leak plot brain
is going to have sensor to see through
little finger scheme which will
according to leak plot and it sends us a
nesting Petyr Baelish to death which are
is going to carry out I don't know it is
going to happen or not but I personally
think that a little fingers that won't
be the result of him trying to make a
conflict between two sisters in my
opinion Petyr Baelish is going to die as
a result of Starks finding out about his
betrayal and Ned Stark which as we all
know is the reason of Ned being beheaded
I'm not saying there won't be a conflict
between Arya who has always had more
rigid moral code and Sansa who has
learned to be more pragmatic re-skill
killer and once vengeance immediately
with her skills while sensor has more
subtle manipulative way of doing things
which she has learned from Littlefinger
having developed very different
perspectives Orient's and some might
clash or the matter of ruling upon
knowledge seeing the difference between
two sisters Petyr Baelish might take a
chance to take the advantage with
increasing conflict between Arya and
Sansa
but both sense and Arya were victims of
other games in my opinion sense and Arya
will team up they're not kids as they
have been back in the first season both
of them understand the game both of them
was bigger part of their family it's
time for those two to start playing
their own games the last scene of
Littlefinger in season 6 in which he and
sense are having suspicious eye contact
many fans consider had sense of
disappointment on Jon becoming the king
in north and the rule of Manor foul
along with possible sense of betrayal on
Jon / Littlefinger my thoughts are that
sense of what made me do that if it all
played a few years ago but now after she
has been through a lot I don't think so
since it's where the little finger is
taking care only for his
plans and is more than aware of that
because of him she got raped which held
signs that figure out that peter baelish
would let her suffer or even getting
killed if that would bring human step
further on conquering the iron throne
all of this in my opinion is that Sansa
might cooperate the little finger in the
upcoming season
but now sense is the one that is going
to play games sense is the one that is
going to manipulate Petyr Baelish it's
definitely going to be interesting to
see Littlefinger finally being played
and manipulated but if he gets
manipulated or played it's his own fault
once Peter said Sansa powerful line
which he recently violated he said
always keep your foes confused if they
are never certain who you are or what
you want they cannot know what you're
like to do next
sometimes the best way to battle them is
to make moves that have no purpose or
even seemed to work against you remember
that Sansa when you come to play the
game this Littlefinger's quote in my
opinion is his best quote why
Littlefinger is smart intelligent and
has already pruned cunning skills but I
don't sense a history of playing games
he might have made a mistake and add
that he only revealed his strategy to
Sansa but he has also told her something
that goes contrary on his way of
thinking he taught us and so his whole
plan he told her what he wants he told
us and sad that he wants the Iron Throne
and her by his side now that sense and
the most Littlefinger's intentions she
can easily manipulate him it's time for
her to start playing her own game I'm
sure the little fingers that will happen
throughout the upcoming season there is
no doubt but a main question is how and
by whom it could then vitória balloon
finger on her kill list and I don't have
to explain you what would happen to
Littlefinger after that another possible
outcome could be as I've already said
sense of manipulating Petyr Baelish
during bigger amount of the upcoming
season and then she gets all she wants
then she would kill him as a revenge for
putting her in hands of Ramsay and also
for betraying her father Ned in my
opinion Starks are definitely going to
find out about loopings betrayal Ned but
the main question is how there are a lot
of possibilities
John finding out from where swells at
Dragonstone brand fighting it out in one
of his flashbacks or even are you
finding out from the Hound if they are
going to meet again which they might
since arias traveling north viable orc
method starts going to kill Littlefinger
after they found out about his betrayal
Ned we're all forgetting about the
Lannisters
Lancers may kill Peters well since he
and Olenna Tyrell poison Joffrey on
Joffrey's own wedding according to
leaked plot and also supported by leaked
photos Jaime Lannister army with help of
randyll Tarly and history army as
surcease new allies are going to march
in Highgarden which will result with
their victory as leap forward confirms
while I've already described his battle
in details in previous videos today I am
pointing on Alayna Tyrell whom Jaime is
going to confront at Highgarden
according to Lee plot Olenna Tyrell will
tell Jaime everything about how she and
Littlefinger poison Joffrey which will
end the Jaime allowing to Alanna to
drink poison and kill herself before
getting captured
so there's also possibility of Jaime
killing Petyr Baelish since he's going
to find out that Peter poisoned his son
there's also possibility of Robin
arraign drawing Littlefinger out of the
moon door but as we can call it theory
sensible commands Robin and other Lords
of the Vale that Littlefinger murdered
Jon Arryn and Liza which would lead
Robin to throw Peter out the moon door
and we all know how Robin is obsessed
with the moon door so it could also
happen who and how it's going to kill
Littlefinger in your opinion and also
how the things starts are going to find
out about Littlefinger's betrayal Ned
let me know your opinion in the comment
section down below there are a lot of
possibilities and how Littlefinger is
going to get killed but one is certain
Petyr Baelish won't survive the upcoming
season hope you guys enjoyed this video
if you did please make sure to subscribe
to our Channel and hope to see you next
one peace
[Music]